let's jump to the story from Newsweek
exclusive Donald Trump followers
targeted by FBI as 2024 election near I
just want to make sure we don't bury the
lead right now and I can tell you that
as 2024 Begins the FBI is explicitly
targeting opponents of the democratic
party that's all that's what they're
saying right here here's the opening
paragraph the federal government
believes the threat of violence and
major civil disturbances around the 2024
presidential election is so great that
has quietly created a new category of
extremists that it seek to track and
counter Donald Trump's Army of Maga
followers Donald Trump is the front
runner for the Republican Presidential
nomination and he is currently leading
and favored to win the presidency based
on the current polling and they are
saying his followers are extremists the
FBI and the federal government are right
now siding with Democrats and accusing
their opposition of being extremists so
we recently heard from Mike cernovich
Scott Adams several years ago about the
risk of what happens when when things
like this occur this is the next step
this is the grain of sand in the Heap
right now your federal government is
accusing Trump supporters half the
country of being extremists oh I'm sure
they'll make every excuse in the book no
no we just mean the extreme ones Donald
Trump has has 70 75 75 million or so
voters in 2020 he has the polling lead
right now which Maga followers are
you're referring to no it's a blanket
statement and that's all of the people
who are following Donald Trump and you
know of course we know that the leftwing
apparatus only defines extremism in the
most honest possible terms they never
throw that word I mean that's actually
part of what's so beautiful about that
word for propagandistic purposes you
don't really need to Define it what is
an extremist you want of say you're
extremely in favor of a particular
position or you would employ extreme
ends to bring your political goals to
fruition what exactly does it mean and
what it boils down to is this is a
person who I don't like who I think is a
threat to my agenda in some way and so
I'm going to try to out them from public
life and the public discourse without
giving you concrete reasons why yeah I
mean it I always try to use the the the
term foreign policy establishment when
when breaking down these power dynamics
for this because this is this is not
just the left it's also the the neocon
wing of the right and that's sort of
what's at at stake both at the McCarthy
thing but a great example of this is the
same day this came out Chris kevs who is
the head of the censorship division uh
at DHS who orchestrated the censorship
of the of the 2020 election the tens of
millions of posts that were censored
because of DHS initiating this whole
apparatus he just came out as a as a
national security expert and said that
Russia's new plan is to Target domestic
political support for uh for Ukraine to
undermine it so that is basically the
National Security State and Chris Krab
recently partnered with two CIA
directors on one of his new Council
initiatives
and he's basically creating a Russia
gate predicate for saying if you
domestically are are against more
funding for Ukraine you are echoing
echoing Putin talking points you're
you're an asset witting or unwitting of
Russia and this justifies a
counterintelligence predicate at the FBI
to investigate You by itself because you
are you know a potentially abetting a uh
you know hostile foreign nation state
this is very similar to what Cass
sunstein uh was writing about under the
Obama Administration where he literally
wrote a paper saying how if there's any
dissident theories about the US
government and our uh actions we have to
infiltrate those groups we have to
release disinformation we have to use
col to probe like tactics to make groups
attack each other and uh this really
makes you wonder you know this was
talked about and I think implemented
under Brock Obama who also uh weaponized
information who also passed many very
interesting propaganda laws in inside of
the United States that could now be used
for domestic purposes when when we look
at all of this I I think we're seeing a
lot of the chaos especially within the
Republican party I think we're seeing a
lot of the disarray that we see on
social media a lot of it I think is
engineered I think it's organized and I
think a lot of it is fake and meant for
a particular outcome that outcome is to
of course make sure no one is able to
resist or speak out against the nonsense
that they're trying to push on everyone
yeah look what you just said there's
like there's so much important stuff
there because first of all cass sunstein
that that that me that memo cognitive
infil cognitive infiltration is what he
was proposing Anonymous federal agents
to psychologically manipulate uh
movements to get them to go in a certain
direction uh he then that year published
a book called nudge which is actually
the foundation for censorship techniques
and so-called interventions on social
media which are being funded to the
tunes of tens of millions of dollars by
a dozen different federal agencies for
all these nudge techniques to get people
to stop reading false and misleading
news and to and to rig algorithms and to
use AI machine learning techniques to be
able to uh create topographical maps of
misinformation communities and you know
Cass sunstein I believe is currently at
DHS and his wife is Samantha power the
head of us
Aid you know in us8 is is the largest
facilitator of of clandestine operation
funding for the Central Intelligence
Agency and Ukraine is the and us8 is is
the Premier us vehicle for capacity
building in Ukraine uh as well as in a
bunch of other places USA actually
custombuilt the digital identity system
called the called the DIA app which was
called a state and a smartphone which
was it was it was funded and developed
by us Aid as a it to create a digital
identity basically a counterinsurgency
tool for political dissidents in Ukraine
tying their social media to their bank
accounts so that the US Embassy there
effectively um has basically a heat map
of when people are saying things online
that might undermine the domestic
consensus in Ukraine against uh we we'll
just say a president who who may be
influenced uh by by interest abroad yeah
it's absolutely crazy how many
underhanded techniques that they're
using simultaneously while tracking
everyone's viewpoints tra tracking
everyone's opinion and then then slowly
nudging it in a direction that they want
you to perceive that they want you to
think and this is why I think we have to
be very careful on on on and and think
critically about what we see on social
media algorithms because those are also
highly manipulated as Facebook works
with the state department works with
Intel agencies to specifically curate
information as they were even doing
psychological uh studies there trying to
manipulate people's emotions to see how
far they could go just by simply uh
deciding on what to show people and what
not to show people I actually talked to
C sunstein I brought his own document to
him and I said look you're talking about
doing all these covert underhanded
really immoral things to control the
narrative and the discourse in this
country and he said I never said it I
was like it it's right here buddy he
never and again totally denied it this
this this is the game they play you you
you these powerful governmental
officials will say something publicly
and then when it turns out bad they'll
just I never said that and that's it's
it's infuriating but I guess all I can
really say is that it's our job to get
those videos and get those statements
out of the public to prove they're Liars
oh and great example of this you know
you can go to YouTube right now and type
in the search term psychological
vaccination which is which is a which is
a concept in a nudge technique uh which
is being funded to the tune of tens of
millions by the state department the dod
and the National Science Foundation and
you can see these
government-funded computational mad
scientists on for the for the purpose of
censorship and stopping people from
expressing populist political opinions
uh and literally they they say that the
goal is behavioral modification and
psychological inoculation against
misinformation and and they you know
they have all these different techniques
for doing it which involved basically
weapons grade they call it pre-b punking
but it's basically like the world's most
um indefensible form of straw Manning
it's like we know they're going to be
exposed to these arguments and they're
probably going to believe them because
they're probably true but so what we
need to do is is before they hear them
we're going to we're going to expose
them to a really stupid version of it Y
and we're going to force feed them the
talking points to just to show all the
ways that a little incomplete version of
that is once they've absorbed that we
give them the next part in the argument
we strawman the ever loving hell out of
that we give them talking points for
that we put they have this whole uh
concept called media literacy or digital
literacy which is also getting tens of
millions of dollars it's being rolled
out in schools something called the sift
method so that people don't even do
critical thinking they just shift
through the top 10 res results of Google
and and Wikipedia I mean they're
basically training population but I just
want to add this really quickly because
another way that they reinforce this is
they have Bots and sock puppet accounts
that reinforce these particular ideas to
Gaslight people to believing something
that they wouldn't naturally believe
themselves because they're thinking and
seeing on social media everyone else
likes this everyone else thinks this way
and that's how they manipulate the
conversation as well as also creating
fake ideas that are crazy conspiracy
theories in order to destroy an argument
before it's even made and we'll see in
say like the New York Times as you
pointed out the stupidest version of a
story someone on the on the right
typically it's how it goes will say
something like you know Trump uh was
proposing Congress pass a bill that
would fund x amount of dollars then the
New York Times will write it is the
stupidest idea in the world that we
would have Donald Trump fund X Plus y
amount of dollars they add something
slightly to it which Alters the idea
they find the stupidest iteration they
find stupid people on Twitter or they
fabricate the tweets themselves and then
you'll have something like conservatives
are defending Donald Trump having you
know kicked a dog and then it'll be some
random accounts with no followers saying
Trump should kick dogs and you're like
what what what who are these people then
when it comes out that there's a bill
being passed like end dog fighting or
something the average person has already
been exposed to a fake version of the
story and they believe the fake version
that's why Ian brought this up yesterday
he said as soon as he saw one story came
out he knew he immediately had to call
his mom and stop her and tell her what
was going on before she saw the fake
news well that's exactly every single
operative in the field of Miss and
disinformation studies starts from a
first premise and they talk about this
so openly that if people are exposed to
misinformation flush if it if it hits
them full on and there's not an
intervention or or some sort of of
filter or some sort I mean this is the
whole reason that they started doing
fact check fixing to social media posts
so that there was some sort of
annotation so that you never got the
opposing Sid's argument flush it never
landed completely because there was some
way to add friction to it or some way
that there was you know a a ghost in the
machine essentially telling you that's
not really true even though you're
reading with your own eyes and this is
is now a technique rolled out at every
level and it's getting so much funding I
mean it's it's if North Korea did this
we would we would be shocked at even
North Korea's techn technological
prowess to achieve that kind of
orwellian you know it's not even post
truth it's it's post brain power so
debunking obviously so many people know
that debunking is usually fake they do
this thing where they're like this
story's been debunked and they don't
even say there's no factchecking there's
no evidence one day someone will say Joe
B did thing and the media will say
debunked yep and then it's like how
where's your evidence and they'll just
say oh that story's been debunked they
they will they will write every article
saying and the theory pushed by pushed
by Republicans comma which has been
debunked comma and it works people are
there's many stupid people who fall for
it yeah absolutely I mean this is not
this is not just them trying to to lie
to the American people it gets it gets
much bigger and much deeper than this
this is the promotion of mass uh
hypnosis this is the promotion of of
psychological warfare that's being waged
on the American people without their
consent to deny them the truth and the
reality that they live in every single
day it's to preserve power it's to allow
the government to do whatever they want
with you but if you dare to question
what they did or or an incident where
they hurt people or where they screwed
people over or where they took your
money or when they robbed you you can't
even dare to question or ask about it
because you're going to have this
artificial intelligence psychological
warfare and and emotional manipulation
gaslighting on your butt like Wi on Rice
saying no you're a crazy conspiracy
theorist you need to be denied access to
speech you need to be down ranked in the
algorithm and usually you are which is
absolutely freaking crazy yeah I mean so
the media is really supposed to exist in
order to solve a very serious an
important problem which is that there
are many things happening in the world
at any given moment which affect all of
us but that we simply do not have the
time to gather the information about
ourselves in order to make informed
decisions about everyone in this this
room does this for a living but your
average person working a normal 9 to5 or
even more hours than that does not have
time to sit down and sift through all of
the information about every relevant
news story even those of us who do this
for a living have to zero in on specific
topics of interest and become
well-versed in those because we can't
know everything about everything that's
happening in the news and that's why
it's so important to have a media
apparatus that you can trust but of
course we don't have that in this
country they've abused their power and
they've used it in order to manipulate
people so they throw information at you
as as you've all expressed and mentioned
here which contains incorrect
information or which simply labels uh
information which is true as debunked
with ever actually going into it and of
course your average person I mean not
only do they not have time but even if
they did have time our brains are not
designed for us to be able to endlessly
sit in front of a screen and sift
through every story and retain all of
the information and know whether or not
we're being lied to so there's a an
important role for media and there's
also a massive oblig and they've totally
failed to live up to it in any real
sense it's not just to manipulate people
it's to mind control people and we have
to understand a lot of people uh even in
in the alternative media a lot of people
who are unsuspecting of this are prob
are probably already victims of it yeah
well the the less you realize that the
media is trying to lie to you and
manipulate you the more susceptible
you're going to be to that manipulation
one thing I do find that's helpful if
there's a particular story or there's a
particular conservative uh talking point
for example that the media is saying is
untrue and it's it's far right and it's
been debunked and it doesn't have to be
a conservative one it can literally be
anything that the media is claiming
isn't true go look at the debunking
because what they'll usually do is
centralize what they believe all of the
best arguments against that story or
position are they'll put them in one
place they'll give you their most
competent narrative Spin and usually
even that is very easy to see through
that's one thing I've done in the past
when I'm researching stories I will look
up the Articles fact checking the story
and if you can immediately see through
the fact check that's a good indicator
that they're lying to you they don't
have good arguments PolitiFact famously
had two quotes one from Bernie Sanders
and one from Donald Trump which were
effectively the exact same quote and
Bernie was labeled mostly true and
Trump's was labeled mostly false that's
right they had made a comment about the
unemployment rate for I think it was
black uh young black men uh being around
like 50% or some very high number
politic fact Bernie Sanders mostly true
blah blah blah blah Donald Trump same
quote mostly false because what does
mostly true or mostly false mean it's
nothing it's nebulous well it means
useful to the regime or harmful to the
regime basically and even even more
shocking like these the factchecking
industry is is entirely government
sponsored politic fact gets money from
the US state department pointer gets has
like 65 government grants this is the
National Security it State itself
setting up these gargoyles Within the
news media ecosystem to censor the
ability to proliferate ideas that might
challenge the National Security States
agenda a and if we're supposed to have a
civilian run government but you now have
this kind of Quasi Military statecraft
Intelligence apparatus that if the
people want to vote for something that
they would have to be beholden to they
can in before it by basically blocking
the ability to politically organize or
to form a consensus CU they can't even
speak the words to make the point thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net